thought I would do a video on communism
just because I've been talking about it
a bunch in the history videos and I
haven't given you a good definition of
what it means or a good understanding of
what it means and to understand
communism let me just draw a spectrum
here so I'm going to start with
capitalism and this is really just going
to be an overview people can do a whole
PhD thesis on this type of thing
capitalism and then I'll get a little
bit more and then we could progress to
socialism socialism and then we can go
to communism and the modern versions of
communism are really kind of the
brainchild of Karl Marx and Vladimir
Lenin Karl Marx was a German philosopher
in the 1800s who in his communist
manifesto and other writings kind of
created the philosophical underpinnings
for communism and Vladimir Lenin who led
the Bolshevik Revolution in the soul and
it created essentially the Soviet Union
he's the first person to make some of
Karl Marx's ideas more concrete and
really every nation or every country
which we view as communist has really
followed the pattern of vladimir lenin
and we'll talk about that in a second
but first let's talk about the
philosophical differences between these
things and how you would move in Karl
Marx himself viewed communism as kind of
a progression from capital from
capitalism through socialism to
communism so what he saw in capitalism
and this at least this part of what he
saw was right is that you have you have
private property private ownership of
land that's the main aspect of
capitalism and this is what most this is
the world that most of us live in today
the problem that he saw with capitalism
is he thought well look you know when
you have private property the people who
start accumulating some capital and when
we talk about capital we could be
talking about land we could talk abou
talking about factories we could be
talking about any type of natural
resources so the people who start
getting a little bit of them so let me
draw a little diagram here so let's say
someone let's say someone has a little
bit of capital and that capital could be
a factory or it could be land so let me
write it capital and let's just say it's
land so so let's say someone starts to
own a little bit
of land and he owns more than everyone
else so then you just have a bunch of
other people who don't own land but they
need a essentially and since this guy
owns all the land they got to work on
this guy's land they have to work on
this guy's land and from Karl Marx's
point of view he said look you have all
of these laborers who don't have as much
capital this guy has this capital and so
he can make these laborers work for very
a very small wage and so any excess
profits that come out from this
arrangement the owner of the capital
will be able to get it because though
these laborers won't be able to get
their wages to go up because there's so
much there's so much competition for
them to work on on this guy's farm or to
work on this guy's land he really didn't
think too much about well maybe the
competition could go the other way maybe
you could have a reality where maybe you
could have a reality eventually where
you have a bunch of people with
reasonable amounts of capital and you
have a bunch of laborers and the bunch
of people would compete for the laborers
and maybe the laborers could make their
wages go up and they could eventually
accumulate their own capital you know
they could eventually start their own
small businesses so he really didn't
think about this reality too much over
here he just saw this reality and to his
defense and I don't want to get in the
habit of defending Karl Marx too much to
his defense this kind of what was this
this is what was happening in the late
1800s especially you know we have the
Industrial Revolution even in the United
States you did have kind of you know
Mark Twain called it the Gilded Age you
have these these industrialists who did
accumulate huge amounts of capital they
really did have a lot of the leverage
relative to the laborers and so what
Karl Marx says well look if the guy with
all the capital has all the leverage and
this whole arrangement makes some
profits he's going to be able to keep
the profits because he can keep all of
these dudes wages low and so what's
going to happen is is that the guy with
the capital is just going to end up with
more capital he's going to end up with
more capital and he's going to have even
more leverage and he'll be able to keep
these people on kind of a basic wage so
that they could never acquire capital
for themselves
so in karl marx this point of view the
natural progression would be for these
people to start organizing
so these people maybe start organizing
into unions so they could collectively
tell the the the person who owns the
land or the factory no we're not going
to work or we're going to go on strike
unless you increase our wages or unless
you give us better working condition so
when you start talking about this
unionization stuff you're starting to
move in the direction of socialism the
other element of moving in the direction
of socialism is that Karl Marx didn't
like this kind of high concentration or
and this is socialist in general I
should say didn't like this high
concentration of wealth that you have
this reality of not only did do you have
these people who could accumulate all of
these wealth and maybe to some degree
they were able to accumulate it because
they were innovative or they were good
managers of land or whatever although
you know the Marxist don't give a lot of
credit to the the owners of capital not
you know they don't really give a lot of
credit to saying maybe they did have
some skill in managing some type of an
operation but the other problem is is
that it gets handed over it gets handed
over to their offspring so private
property you have the situation where it
just goes from you know maybe father to
son or from parent to a child and so
it's not even based on any type of
meritocracy it's really just based on
this inherited wealth and this is a
problem that you know definitely
happened in Europe when you go back to
the French Revolution you have
generation after generation of nobility
regardless of how regardless of how
incompetent each generation would be
they just had so much wealth that they
were essentially in control of
everything and you had a bunch of people
with no wealth having to work for them
and you know when you have that type of
wealth disparity it does lead to kind of
revolutions so another principle of
moving in the socialist direction is
kind of a redistribution of wealth so
let me write it over here so
redistribution redistribution so in
socialism you can still have private
property but there's the government
takes a bigger role so you have let me
write this larger government larger
government and one of the roles of the
government is to redistribute wealth and
the government also has can starts
having control of kind of the major
factors of production so maybe the
utilities maybe some of the large
factories that do major things all of a
sudden starts to become in the hands of
the government or in the words of
Communists in the hands of the people
and the redistribution is going on so in
theory you don't have huge amounts of
wealth in the hands of a few people and
then you keep if you kind of take these
ideas to their natural conclusion you
get to the theoretical communist state
and the theoretical communist state is a
classless is a classless and maybe even
a little bit a classless society and in
Karl Marx's point of view and this is a
little harder to imagine a stateless
society stateless society so in
capitalism you definitely had classes
you had the the kind of the the class
that owns the capital and then you had
the labor class and you have all of
these divisions and they're different
from each other he didn't really imagine
a world that maybe a laborer could a
laborer could get out of this they could
get their own capital - maybe they could
start their own business so he just saw
this kind of this tension would
eventually lead to socialism and
eventually a classless society where you
know you have a central well he didn't
even go too much into the details but
you have kind of equal everyone in
society has ownership over everything in
society somehow figures out where things
should be allocated in all of the rest
and and it's all stateless so and that's
even harder to think about in a concrete
fashion so that's Karl Marx's view of
things but it never really became
concrete until Vladimir Lenin shows up
and so the current version of communism
that we the current thing that most of
us view is communism is sometimes viewed
as a Marxist Marxist Leninist state
Leninist these are sometimes used in
interchangeably Marxism is kind of the
pure utopian we're eventually going to
get to a world where everyone is equal
everyone is you know doing exactly what
they want there's an abundance of
everything I guess to some degree it's
you know kind of describing what happens
in Star Trek where everyone can go to a
replicator and get what they want and if
you want to paint part of the day you
can part paint part of the day and
you're not just a painter you can also
do whatever you want so it's this very
utopian thing
let me write that down so Marxism pure
Marxism is kind of a utopian society and
just in case you don't know what utopian
means it's kind of a perfect society
where you don't have classes everyone is
equal everyone is leading these kind of
rich diverse fulfilling lives and it's
also you know utopian is also kind of
viewed as unrealistic it's kind of you
know if you're viewed in the the more
negative light is like hey you know I
don't know how we'll ever be able to get
there who knows I don't want to be
negative about it maybe we will one day
get to a utopian society
but Leninist is kind of the more
practical element of communism because
obviously after the Bolshevik Revolution
1917 in the Russian Empire the Soviet
Union gets created they have to actually
run a government they have to actually
run a state based on these ideas of
communism and in a an Alanis philosophy
and this is where it starts to become in
in tension with the ideas of democracy
in a letter this philosophy you need
this kind of a party system so you need
this and he calls this the Vanguard
Party so you know the Vanguard is kind
of the thing that's leading the one
that's leading the March so this
Vanguard party that kind of creates this
constant state of revolution and its
whole job is to guide Society is to kind
of almost uh you know be the parent of
society and take it from capitalism
through socialism to this ideal state of
communism and it's one of those things
where the ideal state of communism was
never it's kind of hard to know when you
get there and so what happens in a Lenin
estate is this this Vanguard party which
is usually called the Communist Party is
in a constant state of revolution kind
of saying hey we're shepherding the
people to some future state without a
real clear clear definition of what that
future state is and so this when you
when you talk about Marxist Leninist
besides talking about what's happening
in the economic sphere it's also kind of
talking about this this party system but
this party system where you really just
have one dominant party that it will
hopefully act in the interest of the
people so one one dominant communist
party that acts and the interest of the
people and obviously the the
the negative here is that you know how
do you know that they actually are
acting in the interest of people how do
you know that they actually are
competent what means are there to do
anything if they are misallocating
things if it is corrupt if you only have
a one-party system and just to make it
clear you know so the the the largest
existing communist state is the People's
Republic of China and although it is you
know it's controlled by the Communist
Party in economic terms it's really not
that communist anymore and so it can be
confusing and so what I want to do is
draw a little bit of a spectrum on the
vertical axis over here I want to put
Democratic Democratic and up here output
authoritarian authoritarian or
totalitarian let me put two talib well
it out put authoritarianism allure and
totalitarian is more an extreme form of
authoritarian where the government
controls everything and and you have a
few people controlling everything it's
very non democratic but authoritarian is
kind of along that along those
directions and then in this spectrum we
have the capitalism socialism and
communism so the United States I would
put I would put the United States
someplace over here I would put the
United States over here it has some
small elements of socialism you do have
labor unions they don't control
everything you also have people who
working outside of labor unions it does
have some elements of redistribution
there there are inheritance taxes there
are I mean it's not an extreme form of
redistribution you can still inherit
private property you still have kind of
safety nets for people you have Medicare
Medicaid you have welfare so there's
some elements of socialism but also has
a very strong capitalist history private
property deep market so I'd stick the
United States over there I would put the
USSR not current Russia but the the
Soviet Union when it existed I would put
the Soviet Union right about I would put
the Soviet Union right about there so
this was the you I would put the US
s are right over there I would put the
current state of Russia actually I would
put the current state of Russia
someplace over here because they
actually have fewer safety nets and they
kind of have a more their economy can
kind of go crazier and they actually
have a bigger disparity in wealth in a
place like the United States so this is
this is this is this is current Russia
and probably the most interesting one
here is the People's Republic of China
the current People's Republic of China
which is you know at least on the
surface a communist state but in some
ways it's more capitalist than the
United States and that they don't have
strong wealth redistribution they don't
have a kind of strong safety nets for
people so you could put some elements of
China and and over here closer to the
left and they are more less democratic
than either the US or even current
Russia although some people would call
current Russia well I won't go too much
into it but current China you could
throw it here a little bit so it could
be even a little bit more capitalist in
the United States definitely they don't
even have good labor laws that yeah all
the rest but in other ways you do have
state ownership of a lot and you do have
state control of a lot so in some ways
they're kind of spanning this whole
range so this right over here is China
and even though it is called a communist
state in some ways it's more capitalist
than what countries that are very proud
of their capitalism but in a lot of
other ways especially with the
government ownership and the government
control of things and this one dominant
party so it's kind of Leninist
with less of the Marxist going on so in
that way it is more in the communist
direction so hopefully that clarifies
what can sometimes be a confusing topic